[Música]
es un acuerdo dirigido directamente a la
creciente influencia de china en el
lindo Pacífico Australia se asocia con
los Estados Unidos y Reino Unido para
adquirir submarinos de propulsión
nuclear tras serán entregados en la
próxima década con opción de compra de
dos otros seguidos por una nueva clase
de submarinos con diseños británicos y
tecnología estadounidense el martes del
Ministerio de asuntos exteriores de
China acusó a los tres aliados
occidentales de incitar a una nueva
carrera armamentística la última
declaración conjunta de Estados Unidos
Reino Unido y Australia demuestra que
los tres países en aras de sus propios
intereses geopolíticos ignoran por
completo las preocupaciones de las
comunidades internacionales y caminan
cada vez más por la senda del error y el
peligro el lunes el presidente
estadounidense Joe vaivén compareció
junto a los primeros ministros de
Australia y Reino Unido en una base
naval de San Diego donde saludaron las
llamadas asociación ucus acrónimo de los
tres países pocos tiene un objetivo
primordial aumentar la estabilidad del
Indo Pacífico en medio de una dinámica
mundial en rápida transformación Este
primer proyecto no ha hecho más que
empezar china no fue la única en
criticar el pacto
Moscú también arremetió contra él
el mundo anglosajón con la creación de
estructuras como oculus y con el avance
de las infraestructuras militares de la
otan hacia Asia está haciendo una
apuesta seria por muchos años de
confrontación
el Primer Ministro australiano Anthony
alvanici ha dicho que no esperaba que el
acuerdo agreara la relación de su país
con china Mientras que el ministro de
defensa de Australia dijo que ocús era
necesario para contrarrestar la mayor
expansión militar en la región desde la
Segunda Guerra Mundial